Навколо страшний сморід і гидота.
Щодня 65-річна Розалія Сабош
шукає на нелегальних смітниках на околиці містечка Тиргу-Муреш
те, що вона зможе потім продати.
Для Розалії це почесна робота
і єдиний шанс вижити.
Але її чоловік не хоче з нами говорити.
Він соромиться того, чим займається.
Працювати – не соромно! Соромно – красти.
Ми шукаємо тут металобрухт,
щоб потім купити собі шматок хліба.
І це не соромно!
Тисячі збирачів сміття
таких, як Розалія та її чоловік, заробляють собі на життя
завдяки сміттєзвалищам.
Вони заборонені у Румунії, оскільки немає
відповідності стандартам ЄС.
Однак у Румунії - понад 60 таких сміттєзвалищ.
Частина стічних вод з цього незаконного звалища
залишається на узбережжі.
Потім це сміття звідти стікає прямо до річки Муреш
і нас звинувачують у забрудненні річки.
Скаргу так і не було розглянуто.
Румунії загрожують високі штрафи від ЄС,
якщо сміття і надалі збиратиметься у величезні нелегальні сміттєзвалища.
Під час нашого візиту ми знайшли нові вантажівки,
які, схоже, нещодавно скидали тут сміття.
Офіційно це вже кілька місяців заборонено.
Ми спробували поспілкуватися про це із охоронцями,
проте вони все заперечували.
Це старі мішки, які лежать там роками.
Повірте мені, я не буду вам брехати.
Старе сміттєзвалище три роки тому місто закрило
і звело нову будівлю для утилізації сміття
відповідно до стандартів ЄС.
Незважаючи на це, новий полігон протягом трьох років
так і не використовувався.
Точилася тривала боротьба між компаніями
із вивезення сміття за цей вигідний муніципальний контракт.
Проте домовитися так і не вдалося.
Численні вантажівки із сміттям викидали відходи
тут нелегально поруч із старим сміттєзвалищем.
Контракти були укладені безпосередньо
між міністерствами, не знаючи ситуації на місці,
не запитуючи муніципалітети, які проблеми
вони мають, і які є можливості, щоб ці труднощі подолати.
Це спричинило проблему сміття в усій країні.
Мешканці міста вбачають у таких вибаченнях
лише виправдання бездіяльності чиновників.
Тому самі шукають вирішення проблеми сміття
та очищають береги річки самостійно.
ВантажІвки, за їхніми словами, вивозять відходи
на новий сміттєвий полігон.
Через 30 років після змін
ми мали би бути на іншому рівні.
Чудово, що громадянське суспільство  організовує такі заходи,
але влада повинна нарешті
взяти відповідальність на себе.
Два, можливо, три євро заробить Розалія Сабош
на цій знахідці з нелегального сміттєзвалища.
Але такої можливості для цієї жінки
незабаром вже не буде. Втім Розалія не дуже переймається.
Каже: такі сміттєзвалища є в інших містах Румунії,
хоч і не такі великі.